Prince Jackson gives us a rare glimpse
of his little brother blanket I like to
keep certain aspects of my life private
here's the photo Michael Jackson's now
22 year old son instagrammed over the
weekend showing a group outing to see
the record breaking new Marvel film
Avengers end game while 21 year old
Paris isn't in the shot
Jackson's rarely seen youngest son
blanket is featured in the center of the
photograph you guys all have a drink
until now 17-year old whose real name is
Prince Michael Jackson the second has
largely kept out of the public eye since
his father's death in 2009 and in 2015
he started going by biggie after
enduring years of bullying because of
his name according to reports he's had
the most problems adjusting after
Michael died but as two older siblings
on the other hand haven't been shy about
leaning into the limelight last year ET
caught up with Prince in Paris at the
Michael Jackson diamond celebration on
what would have been the late pop stars
60th birthday here's how they said
they're handling the world after their
father's death we honor our father in
different ways I don't really expect
anyone else to understand besides us
dude right here and so I'm I'm just hope
to be with them and my cousin Austin is
here too and like it's just it's love
[Music]